hi everyone today I'm going to take a
look at what a mid school entrance exam
would look like specifically we're going
to be talking about the MCAT exam which
is for entrance to American and Canadian
med schools now Australia has something
quite similar called the gam set but the
MCAT itself is a multi choice exam and
is taken on the computer it covers a
really broad range of material you need
to know the foundations of chemistry
physics and biology but you also need to
know some psychology and social behavior
and also be able to show that you have
critical thinking and reasoning skills
this is because you know to get entrance
into med school they want people who
would make good doctors and not just
necessarily want to test to find who has
the most you know knowledge or academic
knowledge but they want to find people
who can take that knowledge and apply it
to the role as a medical professional so
I think that's why you see some of that
you know reasoning skills being tested
and also the social aspect and having
some understanding there the entire exam
I think this year would take you six
hours and 15 minutes but including time
for breaks and things you'd actually be
at the exam for that longer than that so
it would be a full day ordeal the
combined physics and chemistry section
is 95 minutes long and in this video
today I'm just going to be looking at
some of these physics time Christians to
see what the scope of the physics
knowledge would have to be to do well on
this this physics and chemistry section
would have 59 questions and these would
range from some that are just
independent Christians and some that
require you to read a reasonably big
passage and then answer lots of
questions that relate to that passage
the sample exam that I've created today
and printed is just sourced from
compiling lots of different sample
physics questions from around the
internet and this will be a link in the
description so you can download it and
follow along with me throughout this
video if you like let's have a look and
if
stay till the end of the video I'll
create a little mind map of these
physics questions to help you better
understand what you exactly need to know
the first few questions we have are all
reasonably short and independent we have
one here about Freebody diagrams and
understanding which forces act in which
directions on an object we have one here
about essentially electric circuits
dealing with resistance voltage and
current and we have one which involves a
bit of fluids so relating to the
volumetric flow rate in itself once you
understand that concept it's a pretty
simple and short calculation again with
some of these questions here reasonably
short calculations if you know the
formula that you need or you understand
the reasonably basic physics concept
behind it we have one here about
dimensional analysis which will be quite
an important topic and is sometimes
overlooked by people when they're
studying dimensional analysis at any
level is very useful to physics to
understand if formulas make sense maybe
if you're even trying to think of a
formula from memory you can check that
it you know works out and that you've
remembered it correctly by analyzing its
dimensions then we have one here about
what essentially would be most useful
for things like Medical Physics
understanding you know radiation and
understanding that would say beta rays
would be deflected by an electric field
these problems so far pretty much all
relate to biological systems and living
things even though they are just about
physics and ex-christian is one of these
ones with quite a long passage so we can
see there's a bit to read here and there
talking about something in the eye of
farsightedness a vision problem that
occurs as a result of light rays
entering the eyeball but converging
behind the cornea so to understand a lot
of this passage we're talking about
lenses and light rays and how they would
you know end or refract at certain
places and how they would come to a
focus
so if we were to read through all this
information looking at the table we can
answer these next four or so problems as
well as reading the passage types of
these problems you need to know things
like the lens equation which relates you
know object distance to image distance
to focal length and like a magnification
equation that relates the image distance
to the object distance those I think
concepts will get you pretty much
through these problems here and then
we're on to another passage based
problem this time it's less obviously
medical and instead is a bit about I
guess kinematics and even springs spring
constants and elasticity we've assembled
a slingshot constructed from rubber
bands at the edge of the table top and
we're predicting the horizontal range
that a launched marble will land from
the base of the table much of this
passage and the questions which relate
to it is to do with work and elastic
potential energy which can be found from
the change in kinetic energy we have a
question here about percentage error
which isn't inherently just related to
this problem but like the dimensional
analysis question is just relevant and
useful throughout physics so they want
to test that you do know this quite
fundamental skill over the page and
these questions here still relate to
that passage and we are wanting to be
able to extrapolate a graph to find the
data that we need and also may be put to
use a little bit of some kinematic
equations so you know these are things
that just relate distance travel to your
speed the time that's elapsed some
variables like that maybe even your
acceleration or your downwards
acceleration would be useful here so the
kinematic equations would I guess be
fundamentals for any of these mechanics
type problems we then have a bit of a
different question here it's another
independent one and it's about well
nuclear physics and we're being asked
which isotope is the most likely in this
reaction and for questions like this
there's a few I guess basic laws about
nuclear physics one is that it's going
to obey the conservation of mass here so
if Neutron is of mass one then we're
having three neutrons here we'd add
three to this value of ninety-two that's
our mass value up the top there that
would give us ninety five and then you
can see that we need to conserve this
number of 236 if we've got a total of
ninety five then one for one is the only
mass number which would make sense which
would give D as our answer here our last
problem here for this little sample exam
is number twenty and it's about fluids
it's about understanding Bernoulli's
principle and of course they're applying
it to a medical situation about vascular
flutter which is when an artery becomes
constricted due to the accumulated
plaque in its inner walls now you don't
need to know anything about vascular
flutter to answer this question the
principles are inherently like physics
they're constriction causes the pressure
to drop and the vessel to collapse this
exam does like applying some of these
concepts to medical situations and that
totally makes sense I would say that
it's not actually that different to say
first-year or introductory physics in
that sense like even a physics course
that's just physics in its own right
will also have problems that relate to
applications in this way whether its
medical biological or even to chemistry
and other things I think especially in
maybe first-year University physics or
introductory physics courses it's pretty
common to see physics portrayed within a
passage of like applications of where it
can be useful maybe that actually just
helps people understand it better as
well if they can see how this physics is
useful and how they might use it in
whatever job they want to go on to do so
really to prepare for
physics that's endless MCAT I don't
think it's going to be too much
different from how you would prepare to
pass maybe a first year physics exam
from looking at this exam you might see
these five key areas of physics emerging
we've got units and dimensions forces
fluids waves and radioactive decay some
of the essential points that you'd want
to study well let's start with units and
dimensions you'd want to know your SI
units your unit conversions how to do
dimensional analysis we've got a few
examples here of often forgotten unit
definitions and also how to find
percentage error so we have one of these
formulas here for forces of course it's
the usual suspects you'd want to know
how to do Freebody diagrams those are
those pictures with the lines coming off
them which show the forces and apply
Newton's first second and third laws to
solving problems on doing calculations
for fluids you'd want to be pretty good
with the concepts of buoyancy density
hydrostatic pressure continuity and
using Bernoulli's equation it often
takes a little while to build up some
intuition and these concepts so I'd say
maybe this could be a bit of a focus
area because usually people already have
a bit of an intuition or at least a bit
of experience with things like forces
more so than the fluid section for waves
you'd want to be able to you know know
about light and sound waves you'd want
to be able to use and apply wave
properties such as the wavelength speed
frequency and amplitude of a wave you'd
want to know how sound is produced and
for sound waves how loudness is
quantified you'd want to know about the
Doppler effect and also optics and
lenses of course this muscle would be
applicable to things like the human eye
for a last section radioactive decay
this is that nuclear physics part you'd
want to be able to recognize and
understand alpha beta and gamma decay
and also be able to do half-life
calculations of course this isn't an
extent
serve list of every possible thing you'd
need to know but I think it's broad
enough to kind of encompass all these
must know areas of physics - doing well
on the MCAT I've known a few keen
physicists who have taken the MCAT exam
or a similar one for Australia just to
keep their career options open in case
they ever did want to go into medicine
and pursue that option
I'd say that's not a bad idea I've never
wanted to do med school myself but it
does attract a lot of intelligent people
and the study for it does certainly take
a bit of time so good luck to everyone
who is planning to go down this path and
thanks for watching
[Music]